you know thanks okay
so um
i'm
delighted to be able to speak to you
today this talk is a little bit
different than what's been on the uh
the workshop so far
but i just thought i'd try and provide
you a perspective
of
our use of sampling algorithms in
modeling biochemical networks and what
uh suggestions are we have
from that field for continued
development on the theoretical and
computational side
that might interest some of the members
of the audience
so um
the uh first i'll introduce you to
constraint based modeling of biochemical
networks
then we'll discuss applications of
uniform sampling of polyhedral convex
models
and then some non-uniform sampling of uh
also polyhedral convex models
some efforts in our field to sample
non-convex feasible sets
and and discuss a bit about entropy
optimization and its relationship to
constraint based modeling and how that
inter
relates to a problem
concerning sampling intersection of a
polyhedral convex set and a convex cone
so um
just a brief thing on notation it's all
pretty much household orientation is
fairly standard the only thing that
sometimes people would notice is if i
say
log x for example is the component-wise
logarithm of each element x
so in biochemistry uh you you can
consider
remodeling in general you can consider
two broad classes of modeling so what i
would call generic modeling is
mathematical modeling approaches that
don't satisfy any mechanistic modeling
principles a priori so for example if
you were trying to infer the network of
of um
of of
of a biochemical system you might
have no restrictions on the class of
topology of the network you're going to
infer so no restrictions that arise from
for example
mechanistic considerations like physical
chemical laws or biochemical principles
um mechanistic modeling on contrast you
would have
mathematical model that
includes specification of assumptions
that require certain mechanistic
principles to be satisfied so for
example in in a mass flow network in in
in biology you would like to have
all the networks to to satisfy mass
conservation so that's a principle that
you can convert into a mathematical
formalism and and aids you in in the
modeling but these are sort of two broad
classes and there's of course mixtures
between the two
but um
within the mechanistic modeling
approaches that are applied to biology
there's two broad classes then and one
is the first one is differential
equation based modeling and typically
here you'd have your input would be your
biochemical network and your some
initial conditions and parameters if you
had them and then the output is some
unique temporal trajectory which is
um
that displays the state of your system
over time
and
in parallel with this um more common in
in biochemical network modeling by now
is what's called constraint based
modeling
and so here your import again you have
the network topology but you accept the
fact that you don't have a complete
knowledge of the initial conditions or
complete knowledge of the parameters
and both of which are the result of
millions of years of evolution and and
to some extent there are
not not known and other people would say
are not knowable
and so you accept that the output in
those words the set of predictions you
make is a set of is no longer unique
temporal trajectory but some sort of set
of temporal trajectories or it might
even be a set of temper temp uh
trajectories that are invariant with
respect to time but it's not like a
unique prediction as such
so
and the fundamental
um unit that we are trying to model here
in our system let's say one link in the
larger um network is what's called a
chemical reaction and here you have
substrates indicated in blue and red
in this case hydrogen and oxygen and
they're converted into products which
are
in this case water and this reaction you
you it transforms hydrogen and oxygen
into water
so
um
all these reactions are in principle
reversible and practice sometimes only
one direction is present so if you're
thinking about this like a road network
sometimes you can only go one way down
the road
and
to model this dynamically what's
typically done is is set up a system of
dynamical equations
and where you're assuming that the
probability of a reaction is
proportional to the concentrations
indicated by c here of the different
metabolites involved
and that's actually interesting
yesterday listening to the talks in the
rest of this workshop and how much
of the theory is related to the
underlying considerations in statistical
physics about flows and
and for example mentions of detail
balance etc those are concepts
originally came out of physics and and
eventually if you track them back you
can track back the same concepts being
related to these equations which i'm
showing you here in terms of
the probability of mass flow in
biochemical networks
so um unlike
many physical systems however detailed
balance doesn't hold a in in biochemical
networks because there's constant input
and constant output so there's always a
net flow in one direction
and you can set up system of equations
like this these
elementary reaction kinetic equations
and and
the the coefficients there the the which
you can see the top line the twos
and the ones that are not apparent they
can be amalgamated together into what's
called a stoichiometric matrix and so
then you get a
your dynamical equation with respect to
time is is a product of this matrix
times some function of the
concentrations
so
so
that's the typical dynamical equation
based approach to to modeling
biochemical networks
and
their the advantage of this of course is
there there it's the correct it's
chemically correct
and you know the nonlinear relationship
between species concentration and rates
is properly represented
and you can do steady state and dynamic
modeling
and compare with different types of data
you can
it's necessary to do this type of
modeling for certain types of
biochemical processes
and there's a rich variety of
mathematical computation tools as you
know for modeling with differential
equations
however there are plenty of
disadvantages to this approach and so
the main one as i mentioned
earlier is the initial condition you
often don't know it so you don't know
the initial condition of the system
uh in in detail so it's not like a like
a cannonball that's fired out of a
out of a cannon where you know the
position of the cannon ball at the
beginning you don't know most of that
sort of information for biochemical
systems
and also you don't know the kinetic
parameters so it's typically like you
don't know the angle of the canon
exactly which way it's pointing all you
know is the cannon is not pointing
directly towards your own army but it's
kind of pointing off to the distance at
the other army but you don't know
exactly where so that's the typical
analogy one would give for the knowledge
of biochemical kinetic parameters so
given those
constraints or difficulties
more
perhaps fundamentally is the criteria
for convergence of the system to a
non-equilibrium steady state are not
known so
there are plenty of theorems
for convergence towards what would be
called an equilibrium steady state which
is equivalent to detailed balance but as
i said detail balance doesn't hold and
so we're in a non-equilibrium steady
state but actually the criteria for the
dynamical system to converge to such a
state is not known
and it's also difficult to fit the
parameters then even if you're given
plenty of dynamic data on the
concentrations
so um there's plenty of approaches to
try to reformat this thing but all them
end up with the same type of problems
which is having local minima can't fit
the parameters aren't enough parameters
etc not initial conditions not known
so it's currently intractable to take
this approach for modeling high
dimension dimensional biochemical
networks
in contrast
constraint based modeling is
um
suitable for modeling at a genome scale
and the principle here
is to eliminate infeasible network
states with with mathematical specified
constraints so for example mass
conservation will be turned into a set
of constraints
and then you apply those as uh to
eliminate possible network states that
are incompatible with with known
physical chemical or biochemical
principles
so for example a biochemical constraint
might be that vitamin c is essential for
a human biochemical network but not for
a mouse by a chemical network
and
the um the challenge here is that you we
there are not enough constraints
uniquely specify the the the the
dynamics of the system and and you can't
specify them in detail enough that there
is enough information to specify them
for the same reason the dynamical
equation modeling is difficult
and so you get non-unique predictions so
for example if we assume mass
conservation and steady state so in
other words that internal rate of
production of each metabolite and
external input of each metabolite is
equal to the consumption and external
output
we we get
a steady state and
this is steady state assumption then can
be just represented as a matrix vector
product between the stoichiometric
matrix and a a a flux vector so the flux
vector is like the rate of flow or the
rate of at which each reaction occurs in
in the in the system so the analogy for
a traffic network might be the net
traffic flow between two cities or
something like this
so
this
this this uh
this constraint then has has been
applied in what we call a prototypical
constraint-based modeling approach which
is to
optimize set up a linear optimization
problem where your objective
is is
perhaps uh to maximize the growth of the
organism subject to steady to
steady-state mass conservation
constraints and some bounds on the
uptake and secretion of particular
metabolites so those bounds are l and v
indicated here or l and u indicated here
and v is your
the rate of the reaction
so his this
problem here is of course
it's it's a straightforward
linear optimization problem
and it does have particular features but
it's you can for the moment you can just
consider it like a straightforward
linear optimization problem
the
the this is the most common approach to
genome scale biochemical network
modeling
and the advances of it of course it's
you can just reuse plenty of algorithms
are already out there the it's suitable
for high dimensional modeling and it's
accessible to a broad user base because
it's not so complicated to understand in
your optimization even if your
background is in is in
biology a disadvantage here is you have
to hypothesize some objective so
so
what happens when you don't actually
know the objective of your system so
for example a typical scenario would be
let's if you're trying to model the
growth of a bacteria in in with rich in
rich nutrient media well
uh a a reasonable approximation in that
case is to assume that the bacteria will
try to replicate as fast as possible
and so you have a decent idea what your
objective d might be
but but the objective for example for a
new
neuronal metabolism or
liver metabolism etc it's not to grow as
much as possible that's that's would be
equivalent of liver cancer or something
like this so we don't know what the
objective is and so on those are the
scenarios and we come to the to the
scenario of of of sampling the set of
steady state solutions so this is now
the start of the connection between
biochemical network modeling and and
sampling algorithms
so
there are many applications of this type
of approach and i'll just only mention
some examples so for example you can use
this for design of experiments to
predict the most informative measurement
to make the you know if you can measure
some of the l and use you can constrain
your space well you can use sampling to
predict which is the most important ones
to measure to reduce the volume of the
solution space or the volume of the the
set omega there as much as much as
possible
and
volume computation is important so
what's shown at one states that genetic
defects that decreased the volume of the
of the
solutions based were most likely to have
a clinical effect in vivo
and you can then
interpret the marginal distributions for
example to to see
which which set of reactions are always
required for a microorganism to grow in
many different conditions
and you can also use it as a way to
detect which are the the
reactions that are most important to to
uh to to consider for um
changes in for example conditions like
diabetes etc
so these are only three
examples but there are many different
types of things there's hundreds of
studies using sampling in in biochemical
network modeling
and
recently there there was a as
a
review of um different sampling
algorithms available are actually used
in biochemical network modeling and also
available as as as code and this is
independent and i wasn't involved in the
study now but the the outcome of that
study here is the pullman the amolen and
arnold are three different types of
models and they're just showing you the
performance
of the three different sampling
algorithms here
and the outcome was that this uh chr the
coordinates hit hit and run with
rounding what was the most um
um
most efficient and and uh highest
quality
algorithm that was used in
um by chemical network modeling
sampling at the time
so the the
plots on on the lower left they
indicate the trace of you know
each time they're looking at one of them
the variables to see is is it
correlating with each other and the
second one is they are they auto
correlation so you can see the auto
correlation for the
coordinate hit and run with rounding is
is near zero whereas for the um the
optimized general par parallel sulphur
and the artificial center hit and run
it's not the order of correlation is is
substantial
so
the coordinate hit and run with rounding
you got some
talk a very nice talk yesterday from
aditi
on that and i guess tomorrow uh
professor van pala will also mention it
this is the one that that we first
integrated um
with with the um
the cover toolbox ourselves although the
artificial centered hit and run was
already there previously and i had
long-standing worries that we had no
guarantee that artificial center and hit
and run was going to be sampling
uniformly and so we were using it on
large scale models but we had no idea
that it was really going to be sample
uniformly so it was nice to get the um
reassurance of having an algorithm in
there that had strong theoretical
foundations because
you can be making um important
conclusions based on sampling and you
want to have reliable and using reliable
samples samplers
so and there are various challenges
still um some of which are being
partially addressed by existing samplers
that are in use but that i i i would
like to introduce you as we go along now
and i say one of the main ones i think
that are really
will require substantial effort in in
your field will be to dealing dealing
with anisotropy so for example in
biochemical biochemistry
the the there is intrinsic multi-scale
problems there so for example that the
rate of reactions in in metabolism
so that that that would be let's say the
rate at which you uptake glucose in in
from your from your gut
that that race is far far faster than
the rate at which you um for example uh
convert a a messenger rna into a protein
so
different levels of biological uh
organization have
intrinsically different levels of rates
but those two
systems are completely interdependent
to each other you can't split them apart
so so when you're trying to model the
whole in other words for example
metabolism and macromolecular synthesis
or expression when you're trying to
model those two together you end up with
these linear models
that are multi-scale and they create
very anisotropic
solution spaces
or feasible sets in other words
and an example of a stoichiometric
matrix
here is i provided and and this is one
of the first integrated metabolic and
molecular expression models so typically
the dimension of those is is in the in
the tens of thousands
and the coefficients are very sparse but
they individually they're spread over
five order magnitudes and the color bar
here is indicating the number of
standard deviations away from the the
mean and so there are some very small
coefficients in yellow and then some
very large coefficients in in black and
they'll be spread over many orders of
magnitude
not shown here but just to say is that
the bounds the l the lower bound and the
upper bound on the variables are also
spread over multiple orders of magnitude
so
it's not a trivial problem to to to
bring these uh feasible sets into
isotropic position
even in linear optimization
these these problems can kill the
existing uh industrial uh optimization
solvers for example gorobi seplex etc
they will they will either report that
the problem is infeasible or solve it
and and then after rescaling the problem
the the solution will not be satisfied
the original
equation so
um together with michael saunders and
others in stanford university we
developed a a quad precision uh routine
for solving the diesel in your
optimization problems so you could start
the problem and then you're up in in a
double precision lp solver then you then
you use that to warm start a quad
precision lp solver and then
you rescale
you you take away the scaling that you
applied and then finish it off with a
final quad um lp uh um
step which then gives you your quadruple
precision solution to the lp problem so
the reason i mentioned that here even
though we're talking about sampling is
this is the sort of thing that will be
necessary i think or some variant
thereof
within the sampling community if you
really want to tackle that multiscale
nature problems in biology
another big challenge is dimensionality
so you can see here as we go from 1995
projected in 2025 the model sizes are
going to be in in the hundreds of
millions and so the the the
we're already the sampling models of
about 5 000 dimensions and and um
uh professor van palla will hopefully
indicate tomorrow the progress on on on
larger models in biology but but suffice
to say that that's not going to be
enough you know if we want to be still
doing this sort of thing in 10 years
time
we really need uh
focus on on very efficient algorithms
and and
and scalable albums
the other thing that's really quite
important for for us in practice is is
knowing the convergence criteria so you
know okay it's great to know that it's
converging to a stationary distribution
but like is that uniform because if you
ask for a uniform distribution is it
really uniform by now or how close to
uniform is it so
i i see a lot of the complexity analysis
this week has been about you know how
long does it take to to compute the
samples etc etc well in practice
actually more the issue for us is like
well how many samples is enough
you know and defining what enough is is
also it can be tricky and so what you
can see here is depending on the number
of steps in the chr algorithm we get
either a unimodal or are not
distributions and of course this should
be unimodal
but knowing for for various albums
how this
how much sampling is enough is an
important challenge
so
we
have disseminated uh
together with collaborators i mentioned
already the algorithms for sampling
through what's called the cobra toolbox
it's a matlab suite for
prediction of modeling with constraint
based modeling of biochemical networks
it has um
uh
it's very widely cited uh the website is
visited thousand times a month about 120
gig clones a month and it does there's a
lot it's the largest collection of
constraint based modeling algorithms and
so in there we have uh
uh now
of late recently added a log concave
sampling of poly convex
uh sets so we've mainly been talking
about uniform sampling so far
of course for any biologists in the
audience so there are uh the log concave
function you can think of it's it's it's
like a unimodal function so a tip an
example of that would be
a a normal distribution so an example of
using this
in in biology would be if you had
information not just of the lower and
upper bounds for your for your for your
reaction rate v but if you had if you
had experimental data that was the mean
of some measurement of the rate this
typically comes with a standard
deviation and then you can use that mean
and standard deviation as input data now
to the sampling algorithms and you can
sample from a normal distribution
over the polyhedral convex set
so um this approach has been implemented
by um
here and it's integrated already with
with the cobra toolbox i guess professor
van pala we'll talk about that more
tomorrow and this is just an example
showing you here when we use this
sampling algorithm
we can compare
for reactions that weren't constrained
with such experimental data what the
predicted
sample distribution in pink is and
compare it with the and it compares
favorably with the experimental mean
indicated in in in yellow
and so the blue there is just an
alternative approach to just predict a
single flux vector using two norm
minimization
this uh sampling algorithm is interfaced
as a sub module within the cover toolbox
and that would be an approach we would
advocate for other people in the
audience who will be interested to com
contribute their sampling algorithms as
we do you maintain your own git
repository but we include it as a sub
module and work together to make sure
that they it it can access via a common
interface so here currently in the cobra
toolbox you can use the ch or or
artificial centered hidden run or the
rymanian
monte carlo
algorithm
via a sim a single interface and this is
also might be quite useful for you if
you want to compare different sampling
algorithms and how they perform
and because just for changing one line
of code you can switch from one
algorithm to the other
and a challenge here really is you know
is is having findable accessible
interoperable and reusable software
so you know a lot of the uh uh
software that's built is not in this is
not satisfied as present principles it
tends to be just developed by a single
phd student and they don't seem to
think about the investment and time and
effort that's gone into their phd and
loads of people might really want to use
their software but they can't because
it's not accessible to them
and so i think if there's more focus on
that sort of thing in the in your
community in the sampling community um
there would be increased impact of the
sampling work and this would facilitate
arguments for greater investment in
fundamental and applied research in this
area so it's a win-win situation from my
perspective
and moving on now to other types of
applications so um the
another disadvantage of of flux balance
analysis is that important constraints
are missing so this linear optimization
model it doesn't include all the
constraints we know are important and so
this is motivated efforts by people to
try and
incorporate further constraints so for
example if you consider a biochemical
network as a linear resistant network
where you're given a set of
resistances you can set up a quadratic
optimization problem and this optimal
conditions to that when combined
together
will go
satisfy a uh carcass portals and
current and voltage laws which are
equivalent to energy conservation and
mass conservation in this case and then
ohm's law is relating the the change in
potential to the uh to to the rate of
the reaction
but this uh these this constraint and
the optimality conditions
uh it it's
it's it only specifies the the flows and
the change in potential if you're given
the vector resistances but we don't know
the vector resistances so people have
been trying in my community have been
trying to sample the non-convex set of
optimal solutions so i'm talking about
the full set of solutions if you
consider or a parameter so uh if you if
you were to sample or what set of
different optimal flux vectors would you
get
so it's it's it's this set and defined
here and there's a bunch of papers now
in my community who've been developing
algorithms for sampling these sets
so what my question is is what is the
relationship between these algorithms
and the theoretical computation
literature in the computer science
community
so these are some of the papers here
some of them might have interesting
ideas for you and some of them you know
they they they they might anyway they i
think they develop
they deserve more attention
and
and and perhaps criticism
and
more generally
going away from just pure quadratic
optimization we we consider that every
constraint based modeling problem can be
formulated as an optimization problem
so even if we get a optimization problem
with a unique solution
invariably
that optimization problem will be
have an input some parameter and the
parameter itself will be unknown so you
might want to set it up each
optimization problem with a unique
solution but actually even if you do
that you have an input parameter that's
that's somewhat unknown and you want to
be able to sample the set of optimal
solutions as a function of the input
parameter
and so the challenge that would put
forward to the audience there now is how
do the established sampling algorithms
map on to the sets of solutions to
different classes of optimization
problems you know is there
is there solutions
are there algorithms out there we can
already be using
and if not you know
why
uh could some of those be developed
because they would be very useful
and
along this vein if you consider a
non-inner resistive model now for for a
biochemical network
where you're maximizing the entropy of
as of a pair of unidirectional fluxes so
the net flux being the difference
between the forward vf and the reverse
vr flux
so maximizing the entropy in this case
will
at the optimum will give you energy
conservation and the secondary
thermodynamics holding it
at an optimal solution
and there's a nice interpretation of
this because it's the least biased
prediction given the data
and however there's still a vector free
parameters so the question i would have
then is you know how in principle would
you sample the set of optimal solutions
to this type of problem
and i've been thinking about it a little
and this is as far as i've got so they
if you consider this general entropy map
maximization type problem
and you can
reformulate it as a as a linear
maximization problem subject to an
intersection of a set of linear and
exponential cone constraints
and so
i the the the concept i had was that if
you could reformulate the terms the
nonlinear terms into objective in your
objective
into a set of
a convex
constraints could we then somehow sample
this uh interest more complicated
intersection of constraints
because it's still still convex
um and in that way could would it be
possible to sample the set of optimal uh
solutions to this problem reason why
that would be interesting then is if you
took the unidirectional fluxes and took
one from the other you would actually
have a
a a solution to the this type of problem
here where we know the solution set is
non-convex
so so there's a relationship of course
between those those two spaces
so and to summarize um i i just like to
highlight to you i hope i have tried to
highlight you that constraint-based
modeling of biochemic networks it
provides a strong demand for sampling
algorithms and a host of challenges the
intrinsic anisotropy i've mentioned the
high dimensionality and increasing
dimensionality of these problems
the need for practical convergence
criteria and thinking about the
computational costs of checking whether
something's converged
to to the station distribution but also
the distribution that you were actually
wanting the algorithm to converge
towards
uh because for example if someone was to
make a a mistake in the code you know it
might be converging to a stationary
distribution but is it the stationary
distribution that was desired you know
these sort of things they need to be
checked
the software that's developed that needs
to be accessible to the to others and
and we i've provided you an example of a
route how we can maybe help your
community and make your software
accessible to biologists
there needs to be hopefully more
communication between the computer
science and the mathematical
optimization littered
community because i think in parts
they're running in parallel at the
moment and they could be learning more
from each other and then sort of more
general question i have about
considering feasible sampling problems
and parametric solution sets of
optimization problems like is there what
the relationships are between those
so i i'd like to acknowledge the
collaboration with president van palla
and and his students ben and aditi and
also uh with uh yin tat and university
of washington
professor enos thiele in in in
luxembourg michael saunders in stanford
and my students
and postdocs hold her man
and her man
so thank you for attention
thank you very much for uh uh
inspiring talk uh are there any
questions okay i need to bring the micro
microphone over
[Music]
thank you very much for the nice talk
wonderful applications um i'm curious
that for the matrix like the 60 000
matrix
how do people usually specify those
entries is like every entry corresponds
to some research paper or like
well-known scientific or like so you
have very small set of simple principles
to determine in those centuries
um
both
so so
[Music]
um
typically
so there are different types of
biochemical reactions right so so in
in many cases in what's part let's say
metabolism
one phd student is responsible for one
one row of that
that constraint matrix or one one column
actually more like in one column
you know and so that they they never
anticipated that their work would be
abstracted and put in a computation
model many years later but that's that's
actually what happened so then you get
pc students that collect
this this literature information
abstract it and and manually construct
these matrices
then you get other parts
that are also manually constructed but
they're more like template reactions so
for example the set of reactions to
convert to messenger rna like what you
get in the physio vaccine
into a into a protein the set of
reactions there the reason why the
vaccine that vaccine method can work is
there a set of template reactions in
your body that will respond to whatever
messenger comes in
and so when the messenger comes in on
the vaccine
it it it generates the protein using a
set of these template reactions and so
we can specify part of that's
psychometry matrix by using a set of
temp template reactions and then we just
input the set of genes that are in that
organism
so it's a mixture between fully
specified and
reactions like let's say in terms of
manual specification and sort of
algorithmically specified ones
hi
first of all thank you for
um
oh okay great
thank you for the talk um
uh yeah it makes me really happy to see
um
this kind of talk also as part of the
conference and i fully agree with your
sort of call for more interdisciplinary
communication
um and i have a question
that is not directly related to the work
that you presented on sampling but
rather on what you explained at the
beginning about the choice of formalism
of how to represent these processes so
something that i came across recently is
these um hypergraphs
for chemical reaction networks
i don't know if you have heard of them
i i'm wondering if this is
you know more of a mathematical
curiosity or if this is something that's
actually used by people if so so the
idea is to
have different chemicals
represented by nodes and then to have a
hyperedge which is not just an edge
between two nodes but going from a set
of nodes to a set of nodes that encode
chemical reactions
and then to use this graph structure on
top of it
i don't know if you if you have any
experience you just happen to be talking
to the right person
okay
so so we recently published a paper that
is established that biochemical networks
are not any arbitrary hypograph
the hypergraph formalism is is very
useful
because it
it it it makes people think that this
straight away they're not graphs right
because
even in the example i showed at the
beginning of the hydrogen and oxygen
going converting into hydrogen peroxide
so that that's
that reaction is on one side there's two
nodes and another side there's one node
so right away it's a hyper edge okay so
it's great that people start thinking
about hypergraphs and biology right on
the other hand
it's actually
[Music]
not so good because as you know there
are so few theoretical results for
hypergraphs whereas there's lots and
lots of results for graphs
like mathematical results
right
so so actually
biochemical networks are a very special
type of hypergraph
and if you take the incidence matrix for
for a biochemical network the
stoichiometric matrix that i showed you
there
it can be
split
into the sum
of this of a set of
of
incidence matrices
each of which corresponds to to a graph
yes
with certain type with certain
exceptions right
so
so
actually now we don't know
is this is this always is this always
true in a topological sense but it seems
to me that there's a special type of
matrix that that stoichiometry matrix is
special you know it's not an arbitrary
rectangular matrix that's definitely the
case
but
that it can be summoned to split into
the sum of a set of matrices that
correspond to to graphs
with some coupling so the way to think
about it is it's like
there is there is
each biochemical network is a hype graph
but underlying it there is a set of
graphs and the flow in there are the
invariant chemical units
you know
so so so and then like inside that then
the flow of these invariant chemical
units is sometimes hard coupled so the
race of transfers is the closest analogy
would be multi-commodity flow networks
in transport problems
but in in that case let's say if you've
a ship
or a
larry with a bunch of oranges and apples
then the rate of flow of oranges and
apples can go through the network at
different rates
but those sort of constraints are hard
in biology and sometimes in the sense
that it's exactly two oranges in one
apple
you know
[Music]
per unit time flow you know
so i hope that
ping me later and i'll write send you
the paper
very interesting thank you i mean i will
look at your paper and then maybe get in
touch i'm happy to hear that thanks
just follow up on that the reason i
mentioned it is
i'm really trying to get linear
optimization people to consider this not
like an arbitrary rectangular matrix
because the network flow algorithms are
so much faster
so
thank you
since
i also appreciate you kind of trying to
bridge this uh make these bridges with
the theoretical community and give us
somehow feedback as to what is that you
really need i i really actually
appreciate that can i just ask one
question it was a little bit fast for me
at the beginning because again you would
be the person to ask
so once you get that linear program why
why is that you wanted to sample the
uniform measure on the polyhedron of the
set where the the constraints are
satisfied
well initially because we had no better
idea
right um so you're talking
i wasn't me now but i mean this was
right back in the in the day bef window
only the artificial center hit and run
out was available
and the idea was
it's the opposite of
hypothesizing a linear objective
you're you're not hypothesizing any
objective at all you're it's like they
it's uh it's almost uh
the the um
the the least biased
um
type of of of thing you can do if you
sample uniformly
now statistically perhaps that's not
really the case like so some people
would say maximizing the entropy subject
to the available data is the least
biased prediction you can make
but it started off as uniform because
they were the albums that were
accessible it's not just the algorithms
that are done theoretically but the code
that was available
and and and understandable to use
you know that often dictates what's used
but what you're saying basically there
might be you know some you know
functional that dictates kind of what
distribution you want to sample in that
polyhedron right which would also be
something that kind of this community
you know is exactly uh
working on sampling right
yes so so all i can say that that is
i'm super excited to start playing
around with the the log concave uh
sampler over convex set
and and
and then it kind of remains to be seen
how far we can push that
but an example i'll give you now is that
the number of people in
my fields who would know what a log
concave function is
is
very small
and so you're dealing with a
communication issue so like i like to
explain to people as unimodal function
even though maybe that's too
too too broad or not exact of a
definition but it helps them say oh yeah
i can see what you mean now you know
thanks uh
yeah and uh you know i appreciate this
interaction okay let's let's thank ronan
again
we continue at 11 30 then right